i have an entire operation around
shopping i take it very very seriously
i've got loads of items i just never
even wear
beautiful beautiful quality i've had it
for over a year
it hasn't even been taken off the hangar
when we look around the high street and
stores we see lots and lots of stuff
but the most interesting thing about
consumption and buying is what's going
on
in our minds the story of stuff begins
in our imagination
and in our fantasies that's the space
where we dream
about all the things that we would
really really love to have
and what a wonderful life we would have
if only we could
have this stuff i always think yep this
is it this is the item
this is what's going to make me happy
what we consume
is an expression of our identity because
our identity consists of a number of
different
facets we have an actual self who we
actually are most of the time but then
we also have
a social self we buy products
clothes that express who we want to be
at any point in time
i have two moods so i have this mood
and i also have this mood
and they're both as vital to
me as the other like i feel like
sometimes clothes help me take on a
character
buying something new makes me feel
excited and like full of adrenaline
marketers are very very good at speaking
to the parasympathetic nervous system
the one that makes your heart just
flutter they can't do anything about it
i buy clothes quite frequently i tend to
do a lot of my shopping online
so i have orders come in at least once
or twice a week i actually have an order
right now that i'm going to pick up
um it's a new dress and i'm quite
excited to wear it
[Music]
excessive consumption is actually proven
to make us feel
if not bad it doesn't make us feel good
recent research
has shown that when we have too many
things
we are constantly dissatisfied let's say
i spend
about half my lunch break looking at
clothes and then a little bit in between
work tasks
and then he add that to some time when i
get home and then the actual purchasing
i would say maybe like three hours a day
is spent looking at
websites looking at baskets returning
things yeah
it takes up quite a lot of my time
before the 16th 17th century many
cultures thought of things as opposed
to the self or the soul and what we see
in the modern period is a reversal
there's a cultural shift that things
start to be seen
as central to our identity
[Music]
there's something really interesting
happening actually with consumers people
are actually beginning to get
fed up with stuff we spoke to three
generations of grandmothers
mothers and daughters for the
grandmother generation
in that post-war era there was a much
greater emphasis placed upon
being frugal the mother's generation
they wanted to be modern
and embrace technologies like the
freezer and the microwave
the daughters rejected a lot of that
they saw themselves as being
experimental
buying different ethnic foods trying
different styles of cooking
by an organic produce ethical products
what we found was that these generations
of women
were all the same in wanting to be
different and the way in which they did
that
was through how they shopped and bought
and used stuff
with the topic around climate change and
the impact the fashion industry has on
on on the climate i am trying to be more
mindful
of my shopping so i've recently made a
rule to try and make sure that
at least 50 of my wardrobe comes from
vintage stores and i really want to get
to a
point where i'm more mindful about it
and it's less
fast fashion and less less rapid we've
got so much stuff now we don't really
know what to do with it
we spend a lot of time trying to work
out how to get rid of the stuff that
we've got
now rationally we might say well maybe
we should stop buying all of this stuff
but we don't do that what we do is
retreat back into our imaginations and
into our fantasies
and so we start the cycle all over
again i would say yes i do
have a mild problem when it comes to
shopping um
but i'd like to think that i could stop
if i wanted to
oh my god that's exactly what an addict
says
you